Hey guys, welcome to my cold open and it's a real cold open because I have a cold and this is the open of the show that we call smartness. Let's go. Wait JB, let's talk about this. Sometimes I get more excited about Jason's life than Jason does. And I'm so excited about carry on with Taryn Edgerton, which you just wrapped filming. So I'm super, super, super excited about that. Well, me too. I was excited because Jason last week, no, no, this is not hurtful, was about to shoot a scene where he, I don't want to wreck the ending, but I know the story. This is funny, but you know the end. And I was so happy to hear what he had to do.
That is really funny. Can you say, Jay? I had to, I had to perform an extremely dramatic scene, right? The most dramatic thing you could ever do. And you know, it's just, it's the kind of thing you never want to have to act out. And I, and I had to, and I think I averted or I avoided the larger minds in the minefield. But I did smell my sad card burning in my back pocket just a little bit. I don't know if it burned all the way through, but can you tell the, can you tell the thing, how you reblocked the fight choreography? Oh yeah. Well, there's a minimum I'm supposed to have this big fight with Taryn. And, and of course we go in there and the stunt coordinators are, you know, are always amazing and they
always come up with great stunts. But inevitably, if you're a, if you're a soft sort of, you know, 54 year old guy like me, only swings hammers when there's a large insect around. You're going to say, no, thanks. I don't want to do the real intense stunt stuff. Can we, can we reimagine this fight to where I just get him in an immediate chokehold and we just have, we do our two pages of dialogue with both of us on our backs and I've got him sort of, you know, neutralized. And there was supposed to be like, like 25 karate chop moves. And like, cause I'm supposed to be a very skilled bad guy that knows how to really get you just one headlock and done. I'm like, yeah, I feel like my character is kind of bored
with all that stuff now. My character would be in slippers at home by now. I feel like my character would go out for dinner once a month. It makes me feel a little bit more of a podcaster, by the way, by the way, Amanda kept going, you know, this era is after, but Amanda kept going, and he's coming back next week and then he's done with the movie and he's going to go and you guys get to go to pebble beach and then done and then golf is done. And then I'm done with it. We've got the genesis, we've got the genesis pro am a week after that. I thought we were doing the pro am. I thought it was pro am because it took place in the
morning, right? Like, is there a pro PM? I'm dead serious. That's what I was fired off of this. What's am? Why is it am? Professionally amateur pro am. Is that what you? Oh my gosh. There it is. Oh my God, I hear our guests live. I don't mean to. I hear our guests live. Let's get right to it. While we're talking about actors, let's go ahead and get to this guy. So sometimes an actor has talent and then sometimes they have good looks and then sometimes they got both. Our next guest has got neither. No real bone structure to speak of. He's got not much of a speaking voice. His talent has been questioned by some of the greats after working with him. Folks like De Niro, Pitt, Blanchette, Christian
Bale, Albert Finney, Tom Cruise, Matt Damon, directors Woody Allen, Cameron Crow, Tom Stoppard. They all worked with him just the once. Wow. Wow. Award givers have been equally circumspect, giving him one Tony Award, not 10, not 12. He's received one Emmy. Again, not 10, not 12. He's not a rookie, but at 54, he's only been doing this for 30 years. And finally, he could be a bit brighter, having received not a PhD, just a master's. So let's try to lift his spirits up. Let's get the word out there for this guy, because while he may have a bunch of fancy credits out there, he may need some work because he's starring in only two television series at the current time. Let's give a warm welcome, a supporting
welcome to Thomas and George Ann's boy, Billy Crudup. Oh, my gosh. Bravo. Bravo. It's our dinner, pal. Hi, guys. Wow. That's an awful lot not to live up to. Well, right? So that was sort of complimentary yet kind of hurtful at the same time, right? It was the kind of greeting I would expect from a close, close friend who doesn't ever have to call. Yeah, we've never met. We're meeting right now. Don't weigh in on this. Don't weigh in. It's the kind of friendship. I text you regularly for me. It's important to keep boundaries. I'm pleased that Will is so skilled at exercising that talent in his relationship. He's not. Will's worse
than me. First of all, not true. Actually, no, of all of us, you're the worst. I want to look up our chain, Will. It's true. Will is pretty good at that. Sean, you and Will are actually pretty good at keeping, you guys text and call. You guys FaceTime all the time, right? Yeah. Kids. You guys FaceTime? I'm not just a phone call. First of all, wipe that shit, that face, look off your face. You FaceTimed me the other night out of the blue from New Orleans because you remember me. Well, because I know that's how you like to do it, like the kids. And you said, wait, and then I FaceTimed right after you did. And Jason, he just told me you made fun of him for the same reason
I made fun of him because he was covering his furniture outside when it wasn't raining. Yeah. What's the matter with you, Will? Hey, Billy, Will's got. Why are you covering your furniture when it's not raining? He covers his outdoor furniture with a plastic. I was worried about misting and stuff and I was just, I don't know. Misting? You're worried about misting? But they're outside. I just don't like to get wet. My grandparents used to have plastic on their furniture and we used to come up with the metaphor when you're going to take the plastic off for like living your life. So you don't have to like keep all the furniture covered all the time. It's just kind of like, because it's outdoor furniture.
It's made to be outdoor. So it can be. Well, as everybody knows, we've had the rain out here has been biblical in the last. Yeah, everybody. Yeah. So everybody's been probably we're kind of past that. Yeah, whatever. Anyway, we have Billy, Billy, we don't want to waste Billy. Here's Billy, the great Billy crew. Guys, poolside furniture is my special. I'm hoping that is poolside and not just an outdoor deck or such. He does have a pool over there. A real nice pool. Hey, Bill, I'm just taking a look at your studio apartment. How's everything going? Are you okay? Hey, he's out here on location. I try to keep the cost of living low so I can keep the R high. He's working two shows out here. He
lives in the New York City. I know he does. Wait, what's the other show? We know you're on the morning show. What's the other show? It's Hello Tomorrow. Oh, yes. Yeah. Now guess, I want you both to guess what it's about. Will, you first. Hello tomorrow. Time travel. Wow. Good. Time travel. What do you got? You got a Wi-Fi signal over there or something? What about you, Sean? Hello tomorrow. Hello tomorrow. Exclamation point. It's like a romantic story like you're going to tell your girlfriend, hello tomorrow because you can't wait to see her all the time. I don't know what it is. Will's got it. Will's got it. So beautiful musical that we're going to start in together for the first time. Finally making appearance
on stage. That's right. Billy, I'm hearing this is about lunar timeshare. What? This is correct. So Will was in the ballpark there. It takes place in a sort of imagined future for America where door-to-door salesmen still exist and we're selling timeshares on the moon. Because travel up there is common. Yeah. It's like the future is going to hold all of the incredible promises that we've all been waiting for, the hover cars, the jetpacks, the timeshares on the moon. It's all going to happen and life will be so much better. When does it come out? February 17th. February 17th. I'm so watching this show. Wait a second. Holy shit, Billy. You kind
of made this on the slide. You didn't tell any of us. I didn't know you were doing this. It's on our chain, Will. I told you all about it. No, it's not. I'm going to go and look back on the chain. You thought he was being rude about now. I'll say hello to you tomorrow. Tomorrow exclamation point. Really sticking the dagger in there. I can see the misunderstanding. Classic crude up. This is on the apple, right? It's on the apple. What kind of place would you be offering timeshares in up there on the moon? Are they condos? Are they like ranches? You can take your pick. We've got A through D units. The A units have poolside three
bedrooms, expansive master, overlooking a lunar crater. You have pools up there on the moon. That's correct. Really? This is what we're selling, Jason. The bright side is a corporation that was started to make affordable housing, luxury, but affordable housing for people on the moon so that all of their dreams will come true when they rid themselves of the cesspool that is earth. Let me tell you something. Bateman, if this were real, we all know, the three of us know, that Jason would be the first person. He'd love to go live on the moon and he doesn't have to talk to anybody.
Imagine how far you drive the ball in almost zero gravity. I'd get such carry from my wedges. Three and a half mile drive. So Billy, there's so many things that I want to get into, but the first thing I want to get into is, tell us a little bit about how Billy started. I mean, I don't even know how you know this. I don't know this story. What was your first introduction to acting? I've got, that's my first question. I don't know Billy's story in that way. What got you started? I know. Hey, Bill. Guys, I have been waiting to tell you my story. How long is this podcast?
We're going to make it a double. For you, you're a friend of the program. So parents were one, what dad was an attorney, maybe dad, dad was not, not an attorney. That was a salesman. He was a traveling salesman. My grandfather was an attorney. So there, there was an attorney in the family. I didn't know a congressman that was previous to that. Yeah. That was several generations ago, both the state senator and the congressman. But that's going back into the 19th and 18th century. There's pedigree. But I wasn't, well, there was a Baptist preacher. And in the article that my grandfather kept, that was, I guess, I guess an homage to him
or an obituary. I couldn't tell which in it, but it was told that there was no man of greater pulpit power. So there's a kind of performative streak in the crude up veins there. Yeah. But my dad was not an actor. My mom was not an actor. So all that performing that I did, just as a way to fit in guys, I'm sure you're familiar with that feeling a little bit lonely, a little bit on the outside. There was school in Florida. Yes. There was high school in Florida. Yeah. I went to about eight different schools before I finished high school because we moved around quite a bit. And so my way of fitting in was being the class clown. I was not prodigious
in height. So getting the attention of anybody around me required you to throw your voice quite a bit higher. So did you travel, but traveling from school to school and always moving homes and stuff like that? How did that affect you? Like, because Scotty had to do that. Scotty moved like 17 times in his life. So he's always, so whenever he sees moving boxes, he gets stressed out. That was more law motivated though, right? Is that true? Getting on the limb is a little different. There was some proximity. My dad, like he's skirted the edges as well. So there was some anxiety surrounding it. But truthfully, adaptability
is what you begin to really rely upon and listening to people, reading people, figuring out what different, what the new group that you want to be friends with and in that grammar school is into. Who they need you to be. Who do they need exactly? So that kind of accommodation works terrific in telling a story. Who do you need me to be in this story? Did you see a movie or TV show or a play that was like, oh, that, that looks really fun. I, I bet I could. Colligula. Yes.
Wow. Really? Colligula. Wow. It's a thing that really got me going. Wait. So you moved, so you moved around a lot and then did you what, you became all of a sudden you decided you're at, you're a teenager and you sort of getting into theater and doing.
Any, any performance that would come up will in school. For instance, if they, if you had to do a presentation for history where they required you to dress up as somebody, I always went a little too far. I always was more comfortable than other people at memorizing the lines and pretending to be. But I went full bore and it was clear that I didn't have any shame. There was no problem being up in front of people and worried that they were going to laugh at me. You should have become a politician. Yeah. Well, having no shame must have really prepared you for the, the, the time that we
live in now, which is just all it takes is having no shame. Bill, you, you just mentioned memorizing all the lines. I will say something. Okay. Having gone over to having gone over and, and having a little fun with the folks, the gang over there at the morning show the last couple of years. Hold for a plus. Oh yeah, baby. I was a big fan of the show before you being Doug. I love it when Billy calls me Doug,
which is just, That was a character. God, you're such a Doug. I know. Doug. I'd like to, Billy and I had like two scenes together and he just kept calling me Doug and Billy's got it. Yeah, but I got to refer to you in a lot of scenes you were there and every time I did
I would go, you got to make sure you get rid of Doug. It was really fun to lean into my idea. That's rich coming from a Corey. He really digs. I know it is rich coming from Corey, but, but he would, but here's the thing, your character on that show, you're so good on that show and you were well deserved and winning, winning the Emmy for it. You have your dialogue. You don't just have dialogue. You have monologues virtually every time you speak and the amount of dialogue you had to memorize for every episode goes
above and beyond normally what people have to for TV programs. It's fucking insane. It is. It is crazy. Yeah, it's a lot. How do you do it? It's definitely a lot. There are choices in, because I, I, I, and it was born out of desperation, another quality
I think a lot of actors share. And I really wanted this part. I thought it was a fantastic part. I had, I had to convince a few people that I knew how to play in a way that, that would help the show. And part of my pitch was that his mind is extremely facile and he can come up with big ideas and express them over the course of a single breath. So as long as you give me enough time to, I need, you know, a week, two weeks at best to parse one of those out. But you just, there's these things called mnemonics that you can use to try to memorize
dialogue. You know, I think everybody who's an actor, I can guarantee never had a problem memorizing anything. Their brains are built to internalize dialogue as they get older and that facility starts to evaporate. That's when you see people start to get panic attacks, because the one thing that they took for granted that everybody gets, everybody's afraid of public speaking because they're worried they'll forget what they're going to say. People who are actors, they have a brain that can accommodate internalizing text in the same
way that people who are good at math do. So that's one of the things that is not a problem for me. However, speaking that fast and having thoughts that expansive is extremely difficult as Jason noted in his introduction. I am not, um, not bright, right? Sorry. We're sorry. Were you going to say that? I was going to say, right.
I'll cut you off. I was going to, I was going to use a different word, smart, but bright. Yeah. No, I used the word. I used the word. Yeah. Definitely. Because more on point.
That has, I'm not that, right, bright. So what I do though, is I work. Yeah. Yeah. No one's going to outwork him. I apply pressure through work. Exactly. And you can't talk to Billy before the scene because he's just like got so much shit that
he's got to say. I do. I sit in the corner. I stare at the corner. And he'll kind of like you, you walk in, you're like, Hey, man, he's like, Hey, just, and you're like, Oh, fuck. He's got this. His energy is like a fucking corner corner.
Are you saying that my ability to learn lines is going to leave me one of these days? I'm just going to say it. It's all I've got. One of the all time greats. Yeah. I'm telling you, Jason can look at a page and you're saying that that's because once that's gone. I'm screwed.
Not for you. You're on so many drugs. You're not aging anymore. I mean, you look so much, I don't even know what it is that where do you import it from? It's pretty. That's my question. All the serums. I know you're not.
It's the serums. It's the serums guys. And probably the. It's a facial toner. A lot of niacin or something. No, it's a facial toner. And then if there's a new eye cream that Amanda gave me. And I wear.
Get your money back. Get your money back. Wait, why? The receipt. All right. Now hang on a second. Who was your biggest influence growing up? Well, my dad loved Paul Newman movies.
And so. Well, that's why you did. Does that why you did the voice in the documentary? Definitely. When I saw Cool Hand Luke, that changed my idea of what actors and movie stars and movies could do. I wrote a paper on it in college. I loved it so much.
And so when Ethan was doing that thing on Paul Newman, of course, I wanted to be a part of it. But the, the, the stage to my mom, because we were born on Long Island, my mom would take us into the city to see plays and our net summers out there. What's that? Will. I, I spend time, I spend time on Long Island in the summertime. Yeah.
You do in Washington. Just like they're like in the center of it. I mean, just east of there. That's exit 34, exit 35. Yeah. It is exit 34. Like near. You go further.
East. I go a little further east and a little further south, but still on the island, right? Like it's still on the island for sure. Yeah. For sure. Just past Manorville. Okay. And past fog and everything.
Is it getting a little bit past even. Is it past Sabonic, you know, that golf course. Sabonic. Is it a little past? It's a little past. A handsome. So that's not where I was from. Okay.
Yeah. That's that. Manhasnet. Manhasnet. Manhasnet. Manhasnet is actually closer to Port Washington. It's not, it's kind of one town over basically. Correct.
It is one town over. In fact, that's where we shot the exteriors for Hello Tomorrow. And the hospital that was on the call sheet was the hospital that I was born in North Shore Hospital. So I was playing my father in the town where I was first born. It was a pretty. Wait. No way Billy.
Yeah. Yeah. That's where they get the exclamation point from. Because it's like. Because today is too much. And now a word from our sponsor. SmartList is sponsored by BetterHelp. So we all like to feel our best self, right?
And I feel my best self when I am infusing my values into my life. So there's a lot of things that you value, right? So for example, like I value nature. I like, I enjoy the outdoors and stuff like that. So if I go for a walk or a hike or I'm, you know, up in the mountains somewhere, whatever, I value that. And it makes me feel good and it makes me feel like my best self. So it's important to surround yourself with the things that you value in life, right?
So when you're at your best, you can do great things. But sometimes life gets you bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed or like you're not showing up in the way that you want to. Working with a therapist can help you get closer to the best version of you. Because when you feel empowered, you're more prepared to take on everything life throws at you. If you're thinking of giving therapy a try, better help is a great option. It's convenient, flexible, affordable and entirely online.
Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. If you want to live a more empowered life, therapy can get you there. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlist. Smartlist is supported by Zip Recruiter. Hey, contrary to current headlines, several industries are heading for a hiring boom this spring, including e-commerce, healthcare and surprisingly, hospitality.
It's one of the areas with the most growth. Not only does this industry need to hire for service positions, but also managerial positions and back office operations positions. So if you need to hire qualified candidates ASAP for any of these industries or any other industry, you need Zip Recruiter. And right now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. How can Zip Recruiter help grow your team? Zip Recruiter uses its powerful matching technology to find the qualified candidates for a wide
range of roles. See a candidate who'd be perfect for your job? Zip Recruiter makes it easy to send them a personal invite so they're more likely to apply. Zip Recruiter also offers attention grabbing labels that speak to job flexibility like urgent, training provided, remote and more. Let Zip Recruiter keep your team growing strong no matter what the industry. Four out of five employers who post on Zip Recruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself, go to this exclusive web address to try Zip Recruiter for free.
Ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. Again, that's Ziprecruiter.com slash SMARTLESS. Zip Recruiter, the smartest way to hire. If I'm at a party, I'm having people over. I'm watching the game or whatever. I just feel like it's always one of those moments of like, hey, can I get you something? And I'm like, yeah, can I get a Diet Coke? It feels so good saying that.
If I'm at a party or at a restaurant or even if I'm just at home, I guess I don't ask anybody. When I'm at home, I guess I just ask myself for one. I'm kind of like internally going, can I get a Diet Coke? And the answer is always yes. This year, Diet Coke is celebrating people who enjoy life without worrying too much about what those around them think. Diet Coke is the fuel to unapologetically just live your life and love what you love. I love that Diet Coke is in its 40th year because I think that your 40s are when your confidence peak and you become the best version of yourself.
Freedom that comes with abandoning the shoulds in life and just loving what you love. And just know if you're having a Diet Coke wherever you are, I probably am too. So join us in grabbing a Diet Coke, doing what you love the most, whatever it is, love what you love. And now back to the show. Now, when you were at NYU, not getting a PhD, do you still use things that you learned there while getting just your masters? Or do you feel like... First of all, you are impressive, Jason. I will say that.
To make getting a master's in anything sound like a disappointment. That's a rare gift. Well, some people stick with it and some people don't. You should see us because they're in tears. You broke up there just for a second there. Will, what did you say? Do you still... I mean, like, I would imagine, let me guess here. I would imagine the stuff that you learned there, which is good, high quality acting lessons. High quality.
You use more in theater than you do in television or film, correct or not correct? Some of the tools for using your body in an expansive way, if you know what I mean, Caligula, are best exhibited, yes, on stage. If I had one of those Tivo 10 second things here, I would back that up. Back it up? I would listen up, Will's, fuck yeah, of a bunch of stuff. You better fucking finish with the direction you're going. Finish, keep fucking eye contact here. Keep goddamn eye contact.
So finish the story, Billy. So it is not... Look at Will's square, finish the story. I have found that on stage, you can apply many of the skills. However, with this part that I'm doing right now, it simply would not be possible not to have acquired the skills that we did in graduate school. Because my mouth doesn't move as fast as this guy's does. I think if we're going to build a clickable headline here, we're going to say,
Billy needs no acting lessons whatsoever to take on the character of... Which Apple show are we talking about right now? I was talking about The Morning Show. The Morning Show. It takes no talent to do... You may have just heard me, or perhaps the rigor that we put into setting up this system that I've got in my home now has not been effective and you didn't hear me. Point was...
The work. Did you hear Will? I did, but I just want to implore you, because I think Jason said putting you into a trap because as we both, as we all know, there's one critic who, were she to read The Morning Show, just takes... It's a breeze for me to do, and I don't have to put in any work. There's only one critic, and she listens to every episode, and your fucking phone will blow up, Billy, so fucking fast.
Yeah, check your email. Again, I would like to... Aniston just fired you. I should just go get my iPad and show you my application that has the notes in there. But for this particular character, I have to employ every single device that I have at my disposal, which include... This is the one with the exclamation mark? Memorization...
No, this is The Morning Show. We're still on The Morning Show. Okay, so hello tomorrow. I'm playing a version of my dad, and he speaks a lot slower. I just had to connect to some emotions and some existential despair. In The Morning Show, there are no emotions. He's really enjoying his position in life, but he does speak very fast. So that's one thing I don't do.
He speaks slow, and I am connected to my emotions, Jason. Okay? I have feelings. So, Billy, you did... You have spent a lot of time in... You talked about the theater. You spent a lot of time early on. Actually, we were mentioning Ethan.
Didn't you and Ethan Hock at one point do like two or three plays in a row? We most certainly did, Will. It was a few years running. Thank you for bringing that up. I know Jason wasn't going to. It was called Coast of Utopia, and I will now do all three plays for Jason playing each part. Coast of Utopia is the play you won the Tony for, correct? That is correct, and that was written by Tom Stoppard.
There's a big deal. As Jason knows, it was about Russian philosophers at the turn of the century. Yes. And if you can imagine an 11... Very underreported on that. If you can imagine an 11-hour meditation on that, that's what you would have gotten if you had seen Coast of Utopia with Ethan and I. And a number of other...
Was it really 11 hours? Yes, we did... There was three plays that we did in Repertory. So we did the first play on, say, a Tuesday night, and then the second play we would do a Wednesday matinee, and then the third play we would do a Wednesday night, and then we'd start again on Thursday. But then on Saturday, we would do a marathon where at 11 o'clock we would do the first play,
then there would be a lunch break, and then at 3 o'clock we would do the next play, and then there would be a dinner break, and then at 8 o'clock we would do the last play. And every single one of those performances, 1,500 people at the Vivien Beaumont Theatre was packed. People liked the event, even if it was about Russian philosophy. Yeah, they liked being a part of it. And my character died in the middle of the second play,
so I got to get on my little Vespa, wheel my ass home, have a little nap, maybe cook some dinner for my son, and then take the Vespa back up to Lincoln Center for the curtain call at 11 o'clock. Yeah, yeah. Wow, about that. Wow. Do you have, like, when you're a younger actor, though,
first of all, we chatted on my other podcast called Hypocondreactor quite a while ago. Wait, what's it called? How to Blast. What's it called? Where do we find it? It's fine, anyway. So listen, but I never asked you this because you're in some of my favorite movies. We talked about this before.
Name one. I got Alien Covenant. Good. Mission Impossible 3? Was it 2, 3, 4? Yeah. But anyway, tons of stuff. Spotlight.
You were in Spotlight, which I love. By the way, Billy, your name came up when we had Krasinski on a few weeks ago, and we were talking about that scene where you and Cruz are mouthing to each other, because they're speaking, but you're not saying anything, and we were talking, because we love that scene. I love when you do that. When you were younger, though, and you got some of these big jobs, like working with Ridley Scott or whoever, Tom Cruise or, you know,
you weren't almost famous too, weren't you, I think? Yeah. Yeah, Cameron Crow. Like when you're younger and you're like working with these bigger names, directors or whatever it is, where don't you kind of freak out? Like, I can't believe I'm here. I can't believe I'm here. I can't believe I got the part.
I can't, you know what I mean? Like for me, I would be like, I don't know, it would be distracting almost. Like I couldn't get past. Oh my God, I'm working with Ridley Scott. It's awful. Yeah. No, it's an absolutely terrible experience. Really?
Because the only thing you can do is react the opposite way, because you don't want to be fired. So you end up acting overconfident and pissing off the people that you've admired, because you're just trying to act like you're not going to shit yourself, which is all you're thinking about. Is that true? Is that true? Oh, I was doing, Barry Levinson.
I loved his movies growing up. The influences like Diner and the whole Baltimore trilogy, Avalon. The Tin Men actually is, do you guys remember that movie? For sure. Guys who sold aluminum side. Richard Dreyfus. Yeah. Richard Dreyfus, exactly.
So there's a lot of, Hello Tomorrow has a lot of the same kind of spirit, you know, that Glen Gary, Glen Ross. We got, you can sell your way into a better future. And it doesn't matter what you're selling, the product is irrelevant. Now I'm, you can, as an American, where the, just take some gumption, the land of opportunities selling is the purest example of that. Jason, Jason takes two gumptions every night before bed, right? Sure.
Are you up to two? You're up to two. Wait a second. Yeah. And one before a podcast. It helps. It helps. Now I want to talk about.
No, hang on. He's making a point. He's making a point. Yes, please. Land the plane. Sorry. Right. No, no, no.
The, one of the first things I did was he directed sleepers. And that was starring everybody. Yeah. Robert De Niro, Dustin Hoffman. Yeah. Brad Pitt amongst others. Kevin Bacon. I was shitting myself.
This was your first film, wasn't it? Kevin Bacon. It was, it was, I did one independent movie. But I don't know if you guys saw it called Grind. No, but add an R onto that. I know, but you have the, Sean has the app though, don't you? It's different. Am I thinking of the same thing?
Okay. I want to get to the film you did called Pillow Man. No, I want to talk about Barry Levinson. Barry Levinson has to play. I want him to finish with Barry Levinson. So. Oh, sorry. So you're admiring Barry.
So to Sean's point before, it, the last thing that you think to do is act giddy, you know, because first of all, we're playing gangsters. But secondly, you, you have to feel like you, you want to make them feel like you fit in, that you can handle the job. So consequently, you miss the opportunity to tell them all how much you love them, how much their, their work has inspired you throughout your life. So I was thinking about, because when I did Without Limits, which was about this runner, Steve Prefontein, Robert Town directed it.
And he was like always thoughtful and poetic and a bit cantankerous and stuff. And so like we were constantly working together, trying to figure out the script, but Conrad Hall was shooting it. And now as an adult, the fact that I didn't spend all the time asking him every possible question I could about the incredible career that he had had up to that point, rather than screaming at him that I understood the character better than he did. That would have been a memorable way. You never know if the person wants to talk about all that or not.
You know, it's a delicate kind of thing. Like for sure. But those are those, those are those things of like, as you get older, you, you, you, you're able to appreciate in a way that you couldn't when you're that young, of course. Right. Yeah, exactly. And the idea that you can take a moment to go like, Hey, I really appreciate what you've done.
I need to tell you this and I want to carve some time out. And I feel like Jason, do you want to, I'll give you a minute here. Jason's created that actually. He was like that on the longest week, every single day, he would start with a positive affirmation with me. He would bring me a clip from either something I did on film or read to me something, a review of me on stage, just to keep, you know, my chance because he's a veteran. He's been working since he was two.
I was, you know, late to the game. I didn't start professionally working clubs in my late 20s. All right. I did ask you quite a bit about how you kept your water weight down during the pre-fontein thing. Right. So, Jason has a photo of you. Jason has a photo of you at the end of his treadmill and that's what keeps him going.
Just stares at it. Hey, what about, did you have to like turn into a long distance runner for pre-fontein? Great question. No. And I did not have to turn into a killer for sleepers. Nobody asked that one. Sometimes it's just pretend. It's just pretend.
It's called acting. Jason, look into it. You did. When they, thank God. There was a woman on it who was our consultant, our running consultant, because she had, she was a professional runner. She ran in the Olympics and she was also in personal best, which was Robert Town's first movie on running.
With Margot Hemingway. Marielle Hemingway. Marielle Hemingway. And so she understood the difference between running as a sport and running on film. And it turns out when you run on film, you're only doing intervals. So you don't want to ever train for more than 200 meters because the camera is not going to do like a pan of the entire stadium. So you're going to do little segments at a time for each part of the race.
So what she trained me to do was intervals. And, you know, it was funny. Some of the professional runners, they wanted to keep just running and running and running. And she was right. They would burn out by the end of the day. They were done. And, but, you know, it does, it does. You do that, right?
For intervals of, you said you've had a lot of intervals that you've had the runs now for about two months, haven't you? Will cracked himself up on that one. But I managed to, I plowed through, I plowed through him. Hey, Bill. Now this is a chat chat chat bot 499, whatever that new A.I. thing. Yeah, that's it. So 499 chat bot wants to know what, what do you feel your most underrated performances
and then as a follow up, what's your most overrated? Oh my God. He put, he put, he put in, what were your search terms into chat? You fucking psycho. And did it, did it, did it, did it reveal Billy's answers? A lot of this is for Billy Corbin, but I'm just, I think this works. I think my most underrated performance is in Ozark and the most. God, why did we cut you out?
I know. I think that's one of the reasons. Over, nearly everything. Everything's overrated? It's a shame that I'm on your program because it's, it's, it's signaled the beginning of the decline for you all. Meaning this is the peak right now? Well, you have, the Zenith was just over here and like this arrived on the radar as soon
as you got some crewed up magic. I want to know, here's something else chat bot wants to know. Archie was locked out. Sorry. Archie was locked out. Were you gone? We didn't notice. So you're an EP on Hello Tomorrow.
You are, and for Tracy, that means executive producer. Sure. Aside from the incredible contractual perk that Aline Kashishian gave you by getting you that, that position, that salary. I mean, Jimmy Darmady knows how to do it. And Jimmy Darmady, another great golfer. Now, what are you doing as EP? Are you out there as executive producer?
You're cracking the whip. Are you showing up on set on the days you're not acting? A lot of silence. I didn't do a lot of that on us. But, but I was watching dailies. I'm in there. I'm looking at cuts. Yeah.
So I'll be, I'll be frank. I was not the, I was not in the lead on that idea. I was informed after the contract negotiations were completed that I was a producer on this program. You're being very, you're being very, very modest here and I'm teasing you a bit, but you're, you're, you're a part of the brain trust there that's, that's doing stuff to that show that is more than what you could do as an actor. Yes.
Well, let's just say Billy, I'll help you out here. Let's just say that you get to a certain point in your career. And this is especially often comes with experience as well, that it gives you a voice at the table that allows you to participate in conversations about creative decisions. Creative, creative direction of whatever it is you're working on. And you've earned that to be able to go. Yeah. Cause if you're just an actor for hire, you, you can, as the actor, you can go, I don't
know about this, but they can go, okay, well, we'll take that on board. As an EP, you can go, Hey, my voice, I get a vote on this. And are you enjoying that Billy? Are you, are you, are you. So it's taken up. I'm going to answer this seriously. Okay. Yeah.
I mean, deep breath. I'll stop teasing. Okay. So I've always thought of myself as an interpretive. That's our time. Sorry. Sorry. One second.
But we're going to have you back. Back to Washington. Big fans. Okay. I never talked about being a clown and my young mind work. No, seriously. Go ahead. Go ahead.
Go ahead. Also, my first job was as a reenactor. We'll get back to that though. Okay. So I have thought of myself. I am not somebody who like the three of you, I'm sure can create things, write things themselves, collaborate with a friend on a script, improve.
I read something. And if it speaks to me or some part of it speaks to me, I want to do it. If I don't understand it or there's a part of it that I don't understand at all, I don't do it. I don't go, Oh, I understand in the third act, we just need to polish on the antagonism there. The guy gets to the peak of his arc too soon.
And then what are we doing for the last 20 minutes? I just don't think like that. I think, okay, there's something about this material that I think makes for an exciting story. And I bet I could help with that part. And if the director can explain the way in which they plan on making that story come to life in a way that I can understand, then I do it and I leave everything to the director,
everything, all the produce, all the editing. Of course, we talk about my interpretation of the character and how on a scale of bad to terrible where it is at that point in the, in the shoot and what I can do to improve and live up to my promise. But I don't go, let me get into the editor. Yeah, let me fix it. I never think, Ah, I know how this movie would have worked.
Yeah, I could have. Now it's just not a part. I mean, Justin has had that instinct throw since, you know, I knew him 30 years ago. He's wanted to be a part of that creative storytelling. And it has always alluded me. And look at him now. Arrested, incarcerated for, what did he get?
10 years, I think? Kind of a 20, I think. But we're going to be here when he gets back. I wanted to get the throw in a second because I want to hear the end of your story. But he's going to be great. But he's going to be great. And he's going to be okay. But have you noticed, don't you see lately, the photos lately,
that his arms have gotten a little bit smaller? Well, those are going to bulk up in prison. You bet you. Yeah. Yeah, because prison is a great place for arms. It's a good place, but I'm just, I don't know. I just sort of feel like he's finally catching up with him. So he's looked good and sort of young for his age.
And now it's really catching up to him. He doesn't look so hot. Use that box of sleeves that you sent him. It happens to everybody. But once he gets ahold of Jason's niacin and beetroot, he'll be fine. Wait, Billy, you were reenacting? Wait, so you've never been part of that process? Oh yeah.
So I didn't want to do any of that. And so when it actually came to this and we had to go through the casting, that was the first part of it where I got to have some agency for lack of a better word and say that maybe that's the tone we're looking for. Maybe we don't need our net. You know, maybe Bateman is not right for anything. Maybe, you know, I mean, when it came to those discussions, can we get more haze? Is there a possibility?
Is it even available? No, he's got two podcasts, those kinds of conversations. They were moderately exciting. Yeah. But the work is what I really liked. And then when, to your point before, I did watch dailies and I got to have a point of review about when I saw the assemblies, whether or not the work that I was responding to was actually in the cut.
And that I got to exert quite a bit of influence, which I felt very proud about. Now, when this comes out and if people have problems with certain takes that were the ones that I leaned into, I think we'll have an idea of what kind of producer I am. It's just a lot of secondary characters going, hey, you know, I got to take off. You're going to leave early for work and you're going, why? Why? Yes. You're going to leave early.
Now. What you're going to go to the boat? By the way, that's a great scene. He's got pools up there. Hey, I got to take off. I got to get home. I'm just going to head out. That's a good day.
Beginnings. What? What? When you're not with your kid, your incredible kid, I love him. Oh, you've done a good job. Terrific. Well done. By the way, he's in film school right now, looking to get into the business there.
That's so cool. He's a real nice kid, your son, Will. And I will say, I hadn't seen him in a few years. The leap I made was, I want to say probably almost 10 years from the time when you and I were staying in that place years ago, that weird place in West Hollywood. And Will was probably four or five or something at the time. Yeah. That's right.
And Archie had just been born and then cut to all of a sudden we were out at our friend's place having, and then there's this like full blown adult sitting next to you between you and me. And you're like, Hey, and this is Will. I go, wait a second. This is you. I have a question about, you know, when you, because you, thank you. When you work a ton and it seems like you don't stop and part of that includes travel.
What are you running from? What's that? What am I calling from? I thought you were going to say, what are you running from? And you're constantly, you know, different cities, different, whatever hotels or one studio, one studio, one bedroom apartment, whatever you say. Do you ever feel like an energy pulling you home wherever you are? Or can you be present and go, Oh my God, this is fun.
I love being away from home for this long. I like this job. Like, can you be fully present wherever you are? Or do you constantly feel like, God, I kind of wish I was home. Sean, it's a great, you know, I didn't actually spend a lot of time working outside of New York for a while for that exact reason. If the draw of home is pretty strong and obviously when you got a child in school, that's pretty strong draw.
Never stop. And also Jason's point looking at him now. Typical carny. I like the carny life too. Yeah. Like being on the road, but not the way that I did when I was younger. Yeah. I much prefer to be at home.
Well, then what would a perfect day be for you today? Like first of all, what city would you be in? Perfect day. What city are you in? I'm in New York. You're in New York. What are you doing? I wake up.
What time are you going to get up? I wake up around 7.30, have myself a couple cups of coffee. Morning. Because I was up late watching Carolina basketball and I sleep in till 7.30 and then I make some coffee and I call my buddy. So you make the coffee. You don't have the coffee like one of those programmable? I make the coffee and drip coffee, just drip coffee like an espresso roast, a little milk
and sugar. Nice. And I put that in my to-go cup. Where are we going? To-go cup. Sure. You're going to leave the house before you go to your vows? My girlfriend, goodbye.
He's kissing people. Shut up. Sorry. I meet my friend John Connelly at the golf course and the two of us walk around in about three and a half hours or so. Out in Jersey. Maybe shoot somewhere in the low 80s, have a nice lunch there. So we're still sleeping.
Nope. This is, now we're, Jason. I thought he was kidding me. You know what, it's better if I take it back from the beginning. It's better when I get back. Okay. Sure. Yeah.
So I wake up at 7.30. 7.30, yeah. No. So you finish. So that's lunchtime. Now you go home. That's right. And you're going to.
I have a little nap ski. Sure. Good. Welcome to middle age. Maybe 20 minute power nap or something. Shower, have an early dinner because the lady and I are taking in some theater. And we're going to go see a show. That's nice.
That's nice. And we meet a couple of the cast afterwards. We're still rolling. And then that's a perfect day. What show are you seeing? Yeah. What do we like? We like musical theater?
What is up now? That's a great question. There's a lot of good stuff. There's a great new play opening this spring. Tell us, Will. At the Bellasco. Oh, at the Bellasco. If you can get tickets.
If you can get tickets. It's called. Good night, Oscar. Good night, Oscar. The Bellasco. Good night, Oscar. It's called. Good night, Oscar.
Good night, Oscar. Good night, Oscar. It's starring the our hour, Sean Hayes. What in the world? That opens at the end of April. Sean Hayes back on Broadway. Back on Broadway. Is this happening?
Yeah. B-O-B. On the great white way. When is this open, Sean? We're all going. We're all going. Opening night. No pressure, Billy.
It opens April 23rd. April 23rd. Yeah, that's so nice to mention it. Well, the opening night is the 24th. Or 24th. Maybe it's the 24th. Yeah, trust me. 24th.
Now, Sean, would you like us. Four tickets? Sean, would you like us there at opening night? Or do you want us in the previews so we can give you notes? I actually really, truly honestly don't want to know if you guys come. And by the way, if you don't come, that's okay too. But if you do come. Are you kidding?
I'm going to be like. Okay, don't listen. We'll be there. We won't let you know. But as soon as the curtain goes up, we're going to go. So Sean, come on in. You guys, a chance at shot. Shot.
Can you see, can you hear me? Sean. I can see him. You can't see me. You know what? Works on their side. Doesn't work on ours. Like that reflective mirror.
No way. In Chicago. Wait. It's like we're in the. Billy in Chicago. You did it, huh? It's happening. Look around.
Say that one again. Enjoy it. Enjoy it. So get in. When we did it in Chicago. way in the back goes, just Jack. Oh my God. This is a matinee audience.
Absolutely, it was a matinee. Matinee, there it is. Fucking fuck. Well, that's exciting. Can we just see that, Sean? Hang on, so Billy, I wanna get to this too before, because you've done so many, first of all, we glossed over Almost Famous because you did that,
you were so good in that and you just shot out of a cannon on that movie. Like it really took everybody, like it was awesome. So I- Are you listening, Jason? Yeah, no, I, it was- Okay, that was great. Let's just highlight what we'll say.
That and Jesus is a son. I said that to you before, when I saw you and Jesus is a son, I was like, oh my God. But so, so good and you've been so good on, and so many things over, everything, over the years, and you were just one of those guys that also, you feel like we're always rooting for it. Like you just wanted good things to happen to you
because you're a great guy. But one of the things that you and I have talked about this before many times, Billy, no, it's not a but, it's in addition to that is, as you're a guy who did one of the great voiceover campaigns of all time, which was-
Really a priceless, just priceless work. The Mastercard when you go, go into the movies, whatever, $5, getting a ride home- Wait, that was you? Yeah, having a night that you remember forever, priceless. Priceless. Wait, that was you, Billy.
If money can't buy for everything else, there's Mastercard, that's the tagline. No way, I didn't know that. That is correct. That was him for a long time. That's not exactly how it went, will it work like this? Yeah, let's let the guy do it, Will.
Yeah, here we go, here we go. Go ahead, three, two, action. Microphone, $24.50, new computer, $1,600. One hour of smartless, priceless. There are some things money can't buy. For everything else, there's Mastercard. Mastercard, Mastercard, Mastercard. That way, that's crazy.
I didn't know that was you, that's so cool. There's an iconic campaign. Will and I had it in common, because he's been doing obviously every other voiceover that has been available. Yes, everything, it's too much. But Billy, Billy as a guy, as a voiceover guy back in the day, when there weren't as many people
doing it at the time, you did that for a long time. I forget how many years it was. 13 years, yeah. 13 years. Yeah, I remember how like it was very singular. It was, you know, when that commercial came on and that voice, and it was different than I think all the other stuff beforehand.
Absolutely, it was a game changer. Yeah, what a great campaign. I don't know what it was about. You know, sometimes we get lucky and stuff, as I think all of you guys know, especially you, Jason. Lot of luck. Luck is a big part of a career. Yeah.
That's why we're great. I was in the right place at the right time. I actually, I did session recording for this woman who produced, you know, her ad agency obviously was looking for a contract. We did one for champion. And I just did it for the session fee. She goes, we're gonna try to do it for MasterCard,
$250 session fee. Why don't you come in and do it? And then she called me a little later. She said, we won the campaign and they listened and they said, can you just use the voice that you used in the, and I was kind of like, ah, all right, I mean, how many of these are we gonna do?
And then by the third year, I'm like, can we please never stop this? Yeah. Once you're locked into it. Well, you know what it is? It's the stability of the salary. So even if it's 10 grand, just knowing that you're gonna get 10 grand that year,
it helps with a lot of the nervous anxiety in a young career. But as Will well knows, you start to get good enough at it that you can roll in and do 10 or 15 of them in 20 minutes. And well, Will does it from home. Yeah. I mean, he's been phoning him from home for a while.
Jesus Christ, crewed up. You know what? I tell you this, I did say to him this summer we were talking because, you know, John does the, as we all know, he does the Mercedes. And he's like, I go, I don't even do. Johnny Ham. Johnny Ham.
I go, how long have you been doing that? And he goes, 13 years. And I go, oh, that's cute. You know what I mean? That's cute. Has he been doing it for 13 years? Yeah. Yeah, yes.
What? Now, what's your longest one, Will? I mean, you've been doing GMC for 60 years, right? GMCs, I mean, this year it'll be 25 years. That's not true. 25 years. That's a true story, yeah. That's amazing.
Are you kidding? No, at the end of this year it'll be 25 years I've been the voice of Jim. That's unbelievable. Is there a better thing in the world? I mean. No, it's the greatest. But you know what though?
It is cool knowing you will. And every time that Reese's thinking, I was like, oh my God, there's Will. It's a fun thing. But I will say that in the 90s, Billy, when you were doing that, and the reason I brought it up, because yeah, for me as well, as a young actor who was living paycheck to paycheck
when I would get voiceover gigs, it meant that I didn't have to go and do other jobs. And I could rely on that. Exactly. So you could audition for everything else. Because if you got a job working somewhere else, then it would take you was always complicated trying to audition.
And all I did was audition, because I wasn't getting a lot of parts. I was only getting auditions for many years. I think it's disgusting the way you guys are talking about your clients is just some sort of this like, you know, job security. You know, when I talk about Hyundai, well, when I talk about Hyundai,
I'm doing it because it's an incredible vehicle. Okay? Jesus. It's everything you want in the world. Okay? I don't do it for money. I don't do it for the fame. Oh, they heard that.
You don't do it for money, huh? I know. I enjoy the money. Believe me. But I don't do it for the money. I do it because I believe. I stand corrected. You are absolutely right.
Hyundai, it's your journey, guys. Jesus. It's your journey. Is that the tag? I believe it is. I believe it is. Boy. Really, really resonates.
So, it's great. Well, listen, only one company can be professional grade. The other one can supply a journey. Huh? That's true. That's true. Listen, man. I drive an Audi.
Oh, beep, beep. We can tell. We can tell. That's the tag with Jason. I just go beep, beep. Sean, you should have said, I drive an Audi through my gate at the end of my driveway because you have. I drive an Audi, but I haven't any.
All right, so. So, anyway. I gave it a campaign. Billy. God, Billy, you've just done it all. Now it's a full circle. And now, you and Thoreau have been friends for a long time. True story.
Yeah, we did a very, very sleepy production of The Three Sisters, the. Oh, you did? By Anton Chekhov. Yeah, of course. At the Roundabout Theater Company. Oh. We had Amy Irving, Gene Triplehorn,
and Lily Taylor as the sisters. How David Stratharen. Hell of a cast. Love that, Gene Triplehorn. Jerry Stiller was in that production. No way. Yeah, and Giamatti. What a, and I love Giamatti.
Giamatti is what a jammed activities. I mean, I don't know him, but what a great actor. He's fantastic. You've been close with Thoreau since then. How are you doing? Since then, and then we lived next door to each other when we were on Washington Square Park.
He was two doors down from me. And so we used to, back in the days when we smoked cigarettes. Tell me if this is true. And I heard that you had to move because of the paparazzi that he was calling. That he was calling to come, cause he would call and go,
hey, I'm home guys. I'm about to go out, right? Is that true? Can you picture me? That is true. And then they would see me in my tank top. They'd start taking pictures. I'd get on, I'd put on my messenger bag.
I'd get on my. I'd say 10 feet. Just a stunt double again. I'll be stepping out in three, two, one. Can't you compare? If you can get me as soon as I get on the bike, as my leg is going over the bike. There it was.
That's why I moved. That's why you moved. God, remember how quickly Thoreau gave up smoking? He was really quick on it, wasn't he? Wait, what? I don't remember that. Yeah, he quit smoking. He just dropped.
Well, I put them down. Like two thousand eight, I want to say. And then he just like one day he was done. We have a friend that did hypnosis and that worked. No more smoking. Yeah, the hypnosis has worked for a friend of mine too. Yeah. I just stopped.
But I mean, Justin is putting a curtain on the Nicarad industry. He never stopped. He and another good friend of ours never stopped chewing the gum and they are fucking crazy. Yeah, they just dropped those little turds all over the place.
They give me anxiety and sort of, I don't know. She just stuck with the cigarettes well. Right, I think go back to the smokes. I'm not a doctor. Listen to this. I'm not a, I'm glad you said, I say it all the time. I'm not because that I'm not a doctor. But I will say, I tried to do one of those,
the vape pen, you know, the vape thing for a little, for a minute, that gave me anxiety too. Maybe I feel like shit. Thoreau, by the way, let's be honest. Thoreau likes to get into the little jewelry type things too. Okay. Wow, he's chewing the gum.
He's got one of those. He's taken a lot of fire. Yeah, I know he's taken one on his. Well, we haven't loved any grenades his way in a while. So it's about time that he took some, we've laughed about 25 today. Wake up, JT. All right, this is enough.
We've taken up enough of your time. You probably got to do a re-record on a hypochondriac, or probably maybe, you know, do some pickups on that. A couple pickups. I think we got everything we needed on that. You guys can let us know. If I'm the gang over at MasterCard,
I'm thinking like, I'm hearing this, I'm going, and I'm a new young executive. He's still got it. He's got a history and he's still fucking got it. And everybody, they love reboots and remakes. I'd be like, let's get Kudup in here. Fuck it. It's a great point in her net.
Oh my God. And why haven't Aline and Jimmy thought about that? I don't know. Maybe just the MasterCard folks just need your number. Give him your cell phone real quick. Yeah, let's get the, let's get the cell phone. 917. It's 800.
Yep. Wow, he's still on the 800. Oh God. Sounds. I missed a couple. Yeah. Well, listen, William. Guys, it's been a pleasure.
It's been such a pleasure. It's been mine. No, mine. I've enjoyed this more than anyone. We all see each other for dinner from time to time. And this is nice to just kind of see each other on this. I know. Let's go.
Let's do, let's go. The four of us out to dinner one night. It's a safe space. Right. Come on, Jason. You do that. Let's go. Billy, what a delight.
Listen, having you on the program here today and let me know about next week. Guys, this just started, right? The smart list thing. How long has it been going on? Great rehearsal. Let's go ahead and roll, guys. Rob, Bennett.
I mean, what episode, what episode am I? Am I top 10? I mean, am I like chronologically? Well, we're gonna cut it together and we'll see if it's really airing. And how many of these have you done? Probably. 150.
Bennett, how many episodes are we doing? Yeah, we're like 137. 137. 137. 137. 140, 140. I've been around. Is there a number you would like to be as a long time deal?
You were busy memorizing dialogue and we didn't want to interrupt. So let me think about that dinner. Oh, fuck, this just took a turn. I'll see what kind of texts I get from Barnett over the next 24 hours to see if we can make this shit happen. Billy, we love you.
Billy, we love you. We do love you. I miss you. Love you guys. Stop working so hard. Promoting Hello Tomorrow. Hello Tomorrow. Hello Tomorrow.
Hello Tomorrow. Exclamation point. Mastercard. You'll love Hello Tomorrow. Watching Hello Tomorrow with your friends? Priceless. There you go. There are some things money can't buy for everything else.
I can't wait, Billy. That sounds like everything I'm for that show. I can't wait. Excellent. I hope you enjoy. There's some sci-fi in it. You'll like that part. That's why I'm gonna tune in.
Yes. All right. Love you guys. Love you guys. Me and it. Bye, Billy. Love you guys. Bye, buddy.
Bye. Oh, bye. Jay, when did you ask him to be on? Like, Billy's so great. I mean, I can't remember when. If I'm Billy, I'm mad at you. You know what I mean? Oh, really?
Like, Krasinski mad? Hey. You know? That was inexcusable. What part? What are you talking about? Well, it will took 136 episodes before he invited John Krasinski on the show.
Oh, I know. Like, were not friends with him or something. God. I know. Fuck off. No, that Billy crewed up. I kept trying to figure out a joke to turn the last name into Crudite somehow crude up.
Or cut up. Like, he's a real cut up. Yeah. Boy, I'm glad you didn't. Yeah, just don't have it. Yeah, it would have been a real side slapper. Oh, man. Is that what it is?
No, knee slapper. But one of those actors that you see. You know, one of the sort of things about being a wordsmith is you have to know words. Oh. You know what I mean? Yeah. Yes.
So. But Billy's one of those actors that's been in like a million things and he holds never not work. And they've all been great. And he's never sucked. And never. Never sucked.
He's the kind of thing. Well, like if you see his name in a cast, you're like, oh, this is a high quality project. That's exactly right. Yeah. He's so good and he's so sweet and he's so handsome. And he's just got it all. He's handsome.
Hey, hey, hey. He's really handsome, man. Sorry. I think you could take a shower or something. Sorry. You know what though? I can't wait to see his new show, Hello Tomorrow. I wonder what the sequel would be.
It's Hello Tomorrow. And then maybe. Would it be? Bye. Don't go up high. Don't go up high. And then don't repeat it three times. Bye.
Bye, tomorrow. Bye. Bye, tomorrow. Bye. Bye, tomorrow. Hello, tomorrow. Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjarf. Smart. Less.
Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts. Or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music. Or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. Hey, I'm Mike Corey, the host of Wondery's podcast Against the Odds.
Each week, we share thrilling true stories of survival and put you in the shoes of the heroes who live to tell the tale. In our next season, we take you to a remote corner of Alaska that's home to one of the densest brown bear populations in the world. But in recent years, the change in climate has caused a shortage of the bear's natural food sources.
More and more bears are venturing into the town of Haines, Alaska, in search of food, putting residents on edge. Then everyone's worst fears are realized. Three experienced back country skiers unknowingly ski over a den and awaken a mother bear and her cub. She attacks, and one of the men is left fighting for his life while his friends desperately wait for help to arrive.
Follow Against the Odds wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.